Joe Biden's border crisis causing chaos
in a Democrat City more than 100
protesters brawling outside New York
city mayor Eric Adams residents at a
rally against the city's failed handling
of the situation over a 100,000 migrants
have flooded the Big Apple and residents
say it's time to stop putting migrants
before Americans we don't want freaking
symbolism we want a
plan we want
action we want these migrants out of our
city put him on a bus he said who's your
daddy and they said you are Joe and ever
since then it's been a
tsunam and another big Democrat City
suffering the consequences of Biden's
open border Texas governor Greg Abbott
sending his tth bus full of illegals to
La the city's Democrat mayor Karen bass
lashing out Los Angeles has not extended
an invitation asking for people to come
this is a political
Act
okay uh Dana Perino uh things are
getting a little heated in the streets
what do you think that means well I
don't like people being violent towards
each other but I also understand the
frustration and it's getting hotter and
the Adams Administration remember you
know you know the brown stuff that rolls
downhill um so it's coming right it's
happening to the mayor and to the
governor and they're not going to take
it for long right because they're going
to suffer under it so they are slowly
but surely turning the attention to
Biden where it belongs and the thing
about Karen bass what we didn't show you
is that just a couple of years ago she
was talking about how great it is that
Los Angeles is a sanctuary City so this
continues to be the uh political own
goal of the decade because they said
they wanted them and now when they have
to share the burden of the Border States
they're freaking out and I understand
the citizens of those cities saying wait
what is happening and you are talking in
New York about sports apparatus being
taken over by migrants with big tents
this is where kids used to play soccer
do you think kids don't need to play
soccer anymore and now you have 3,000 um
single males staying in this place and
how long are they going to be here I
think Eric Adams has completely misread
this right to shelter law in New York it
was meant for Citizens not people who
are not citizens and every time they
tell Joe Biden that they need more
resources and more work permits what
does that tell migrants and the coyotes
send more here so I think that Biden is
going to have to do deal with this at
some point but it's kind of tipping into
one of those things where you could see
that remember last year in the midterms
the Republicans were able to win four or
five congressional seats in New York
four and that was kind of a surprise to
people what what was the reason it was
mainly crime and security and now you
add this on top of it and there could be
again like a little bit of a pendulum
shift back to the party who is saying we
will actually try to deal with this in a
responsible way do you see that too that
that this is hurting Democrats in the
next election C potentially I think
potentially because immigration has long
been an issue that parties have
benefited from making political right
they go back and forth back and forth
and no one ever gets anything solved
which is why it is pretty ridiculous for
you oh you're making it political by
sending people here well that proved
that you were just being political when
you said this was a a sanctuary right
because the bare minimum if you tell
somebody I have a sanctuary for you the
bare minimum of what that requires is
for you to allow them into the sanctuary
that you've provided and if I don't it's
what a lot of these problems are more of
a welfare problem than a migrant problem
I mean these migrants if they're being
told this is a sanctuary if they're
being if they're being told you're going
to have a place to stay you're going to
have food you're going to have all of
these things why wouldn't they come we
can't be surprised when they come but
you also can't be surprised when you're
being called on it because that is what
you said and it's one thing to say that
and say this is a sanctuary we're not
like those mean jerks who won't welcome
you and then to have a completely
different attitude when people show up
up and actually you know call you out on
what you were saying then you were being
political also I think that
unfortunately it's up to Congress to
solve this issue and I say unfortunately
because they don't really seem quite
interested in doing that it's up to
Congress how many times have we heard
that har Jun so I think cats on to
something you think about the number of
hearings and let me say I think it's
smart for these Mayors and these
Governors across the country um um to
bust people to these other cities
because the burden has to be shared
across the country
uh and frankly the politics of it will
force hopefully Force an answer now to
your point about Congress to date I've
only know I know of only one hearing
that Jim Jordan and the team have had
and they did it on the border and we
covered it now they didn't have a piece
of legislation come from that if I were
them and I'm not them but if I were them
I'd pass something in the house and be
every day talking about you can talk
about Hunter Biden do all that and
that's fine but talk about how also
waiting in the Senate is a border bill
is a bill that will provide more money
for the DEA for law enforcement for
border patrol and even the military to
think creatively about how we interdict
down at the border to help ensure that
drugs don't keep coming across the
border build a wall invest in the
hemisphere the investment should look
like investing in job training in
schools to ensure that if indeed we
block the border and close off the
border with the wall that people have
some opportunity and chance where they
are I think the real story of this one
of the real stories is that America
remains we never thought it differently
it Remains the greatest country in the
world people are willing to walk
hundreds if not thousands of miles to
try to get to our border now the Joe
Biden that I knew and I I grew to
respect and I respect him now as
president he was in the US senator I was
in the Congress he believed in trying to
find bipartisan solutions to issues if
he were in the Senate he'd get he'd get
10 to 20 bipartisan group of senators to
do the exact things that we've talked
about on this show over and over again
and force the house and or Force the
president vice president whomever that
might be to either sign it or not sign
it and if they didn't sign it Democrats
would use that as an issue in the fall
this issue is not going to go away I
know some in my party may think that
abort that abortion and guns are going
to be the issue the cultural issues that
impact this race and some of the other
side think that it's crime and the
Border maybe they're right but I'd love
for us to try to get together and solve
crime solve the Border issue solve the
abortion issue and say let's say
abortion issue give that's figure out a
way to give people a right give some
some certain number of weeks and even
solve the gun issue the the the board
issue to me we've talked more about it
and politicize it more than we've tried
to solve it I'm 53 when I was in
Congress which was 27 years ago we were
talking about this it's some point the
answers are screaming Us in the face
screaming at us in the face let's solve
the problem you look good for 53 by the
way thank you sir I appreciate judge
Janine you know I don't know that we
need to be as creative and so perplexed
by all of this there is a law in this
country and the law is clear if you want
to come to America you apply and if you
want to come here you wait in line like
everybody else you don't have the right
to demand entry you don't have the right
right to force entry you don't have the
right to impose upon the American people
a financial burden so great and so
Monumental that we simply cannot afford
it and the amazing part of what M mayor
Adams is doing is he's moaning now about
100,000 people now what he has to spread
he says among the Burrows of New York
City so what is 100,000 compared to 5
million that have come through in the
last two years of the Biden
Administration that is 2% 2% and you're
moaning and groaning about it okay this
is a problem that can end if we close
the border all right and I know that
everybody is a hypocrite in Washington
you accept it of course than say hip is
well when you were in Washington well
because you know we're a sanctuary City
come here we want the poor we want
everybody come give them Asylum we're
Americans this is who we are not who we
are and then mayor Karen Bass I got to
love this one she says La is not
extended an invitation to you to show up
in Los Angeles and it is it is on top of
that these people are vulnerable and
they had to travel through a storm you
made them travel through a storm are you
kidding they came a th000 miles they
came 500 miles and she's moaning about
they are not credible this is all tribal
this is all politics it's not going to
be solved because neither party wants to
allow the other party to take credit now
you know the the the the fight that
occurred at Gracie Mansion is New
Yorkers who were saying you know this
isn't about hate the woman who fired who
burnt the American flag this is about
having Americans have a say in where
their kids are going to play soccer
whether the schools are going to be open
for their kids whether or not they're
going to be in a position to have to pay
double the school taxes because they
have to hire all kinds of new teachers
to accommodate this you know this is
about equal protection under the law
that we is American citizens have to
claim and it's not about hate it's about
finally following the law yeah I
guarantee you the woman that burned the
flag probably didn't put an illegal up
in her apartment oh coming up is this
how you should handle climate freaks
blocking
traffic take all of you out you better
move cops bulldozing through an EC mob
blocking the road hi everyone I'm Brian
kilme I want you to do me a favor I want
you to click to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page this is the only way
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now